[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another user
interface tutorial for the Gotto engine
we're going to be doing one more
animation based tutorial before we get
into some other UI stuff for this one
we're going to create an animation when
we first load our control noes this
could be when the uh the menu pops up
you have it scale up or fade in and to
do this we need to do a couple of things
and add some more logic to our animation
component and before I forget as always
if you want to just grab the source
files and and take it from there you can
do that on my patreon and the link for
that is in the description there's also
tons of other stuff on there from the
firstperson shooter tutorial series and
some other things that I'm working on so
check that out now before we jump into
the the logic that we're adding here
we're going to create some some
variables and then we'll be able to work
with those now if we have an animation
that we want to run whenever something
first loads into our scene we want to be
able to set that with a Boolean so we're
going to add another export variable
here at the top in our settings or our
our options group rather and we're call
this enter animation and this is just
going to be a Boolean we'll set this to
false by default so we can turn this on
and off and if you remember from our our
hover settings from our multiple
animation episode we created all of
these hovering settings all these
variables for our hover we're going to
do the same thing for our enter
animation so these groups are sort of
like uh you know different animation
types and you want to be able to set
each of these differently because you
don't want the hover necessarily to be
the same as your enter animation and so
that's why we're setting these apart
I'll make it a little bit easier on you
we can just copy this and and paste it
and let's rename this to enter settings
and obviously it's going to be very
unhappy because we have copies of our
variable so we're just going to rename
all of these hovers here to enter there
we go so we have all of our our new
enter variables fact we save that go to
our components we've got a brand new
group and there are our separate
animation settings now we're going to
add one more um to this group and I'll
I'll get into why we need it later on
but you're going to be happy you have it
and this is going to be called a wait
for variable
and for our type we're going to need
another animation component so briefly
let's say you wanted to have each of
these buttons enter in at a different
time now you could use the delay that we
did in the last episode and just
manually figure out how long it's going
to take for that one to jump in delay it
run that one you could do that if you
just wanted to wait until let's say the
new game button here animated and it
entered into the uh the scene and then
you wanted to run your continue button
animation that's why we're going to have
this weight for variable so we've got
that added we also need to add a new
enters
value here this is where we're setting
uh you know how these values are are
being adjusted whenever we run our tween
function so we'll add that and we're
also going to add a constant
here just to make this
clean and we're going to call this
immediate transition and it's going to
make sense in just a minute why we need
this and to do that we'll just throw in
the uh
translinear type next let's jump down to
our setup function and as a reminder
we're running this uh as a deferred call
so we don't get really screwy you know
size and scale and position settings for
our child control nodes by running this
called the furd we're getting the final
size settings and if you don't it's it's
going to be odd it's you're not going to
get what you think you're going to get
so we have one for our our default
values we're setting these dictionaries
up that we're going to run through and
our our add tween function we've got one
for default hover and now we need to add
one for our inter
values so this will be a new dictionary
and we're going to do the same settings
we have scale we're going to use our
inter scale we have position we're going
to use the target position plus our
inter position it's very similar to how
we set up our our hover values and our
rotation we'll do the same
thing
Target rotation plus the degree to
Radian in function and then our inter
rotation variable we'll adjust our
size Target size plus inter size and
then the self modulate with our inter
modulate all right so we have all of
these inter values that means we can run
the uh tween function it's unhappy I
forgot a comma there we go so we have
our enter values for now we're just
going to get the enter animation working
first and then we're going to do the
wait for fix because that's more of a
fix issue than a feature I mean it is a
feature but it's a problem that we need
to fix later on so we're going to do a
new function because this needs to be a
little bit more individualized for our
our enter so we're call this on
enter we're not returning anything so we
void it and when we run this function in
fact let's pass this and and run it
first so in our setup after we've
connected our
signals if we are wanting to do an inter
animation so if we've checked that that
Boolean in our inspector then we want to
run our onenter function and then we're
going to add to this later but for now
that's all we need so then in our Onin
function we're going to run just our
regular tween and we're going to fill it
with our values and those are going to
be our inter values we'll make these run
in parallel actually this should be this
should always be true I'll explain this
in a second but should always be true so
when we're entering in um imagine you
you've loaded your control node it has a
default value that's how it loads but if
you're making it scale up from zero you
don't want to scale it from one and then
scale it to zero that that's not going
to look good you want it to start as
zero and we're going to use a tween to
do that and we can do that by setting
the time it takes to do the tween to 0
seconds
and that's why we want to run everything
at the same time we just want to reset
all those values back to uh whatever our
inter values are and do it immediately
so we set that to zero we don't want any
delay we set that to zero and then this
is where we're going to use our um
immediate transition constant because we
don't want any weird um bouncing effect
if you ever look at the transitions uh
and I I'll actually leave a link to that
in the description if you ever use the
uh the Transitions and look at the graph
some of them kind of Bounce above and
below zero and one that's going to uh
kind of do some weird stuff we just want
everything to be zeroed out we don't
want anything to have a weird bounce in
between those values so that's why we're
using the immediate transition and we've
set that to just a basic linear
transition and then easing easing
doesn't really matter as much so we can
just set that to to hover easing for
now all right so we've got our our tween
it's not happy with me enter values I
forgot this s again I always I should
just call them value enter values don't
forget your s all right now the case
might be that we're waiting for
something okay so think of we we've run
this enter function we've zeroed
everything out we've gone to the uh the
value that we want to enter in our
initial values now let's say we wanted
to wait right we wanted to wait until
the parent loaded and it animated so
we're going to wait if we are waiting if
wait for we're going to pass we're going
to stop right there because we're going
to do our actual entering animation in a
different way but if we're not waiting
for anything then we want to run our
animation and that's going to going to
be just another add tween we're going to
go to our default values so we're going
to go back to our our home base our
foundation we'll use our parallel
animations
value we will use our enter time in this
case whoops there we go going to use our
enter time in this case our enter
delay because we did add that right
pretty sure we did yes we did we have
our enter delay and then our enter
transition these are just all our our
enter variables that we
added and our enter easing value okay so
now if we're not waiting for anything we
haven't put any uh value within that
variable we're going to just run our
function in fact we should be able to
test this uh as it stands and let's go
to our our new game and let's have this
enter in let's just do a scale so we're
going to zero it out and then the
transition can be just a a back and it's
just it's going to pop up and the enter
time let's do just 0. five to make it
very obvious all right let's run that
and it didn't do anything don't forget
to check your inter
animation let's try it now and there we
go so if you saw that had a little bit
of a bounce in there that's that um
weird effect so if we do linear then it
it's just zero 0 to one so we have that
animation we can delay that maybe by a
second now because we've we're working
in this this function that we've created
and added these you know delay features
to and we're cycling through all these
properties all of these settings are are
going to work the same for whatever type
of Animation you create so that's why we
can just add a delay to this ENT
animation because we created the delay
functionality to our component in the
last episode so that's already that's
already working out of the box we're
good to go with that now let's say I
wanted to have the continue button enter
in after the new game button they're
both entering they both have those
animations and if I just play it they
they just they just go they start from
the same point let's say I wanted to
wait that's why we have this wait for
option so I can set uh to the animation
component the animation of the the new
game button and I can set that wait for
to to load to that and we got to do a
couple of things in our code and we're
going to be waiting in fact if I run
that right now because we set that
remember we we passed that continue
button is not going to do anything it's
just going to sit there so we need to
run that animation in a different way
and really in in our logic it's we need
to run that animation when this
animation is done so what we need to do
is fire a signal when the animation is
done and and we'll listen for it so
let's go to the top we're going to add a
new
signal and we'll call this entered again
whenever you create signals try to do
like a past tense we basically have two
situations that could occur either the
parent hasn't enter animation or it
doesn't and if it doesn't we just want
to say it's entered it's done if it does
we need to wait for that twe that
animation to finish and then we're going
to emit that signal so if we go up to
our
right here in our setup we've done all
the the fancy loading of the variables
we connected our signals we're checking
if we're doing an enter animation and
then we're running that on enter if
we're not running an enter
animation then let's just admit our
signal because we're done our button has
loaded it's animated whatever it's going
to do it's done we'll emit it there and
then if it is running an animation let's
go to our add tween animation and we
need to actually create another
parameter because we're we're creating a
different type of Animation here and we
need to check for something and what we
need to check for is whether or not this
animation is an entering animation okay
that's going to throw all these errors
because we were missing a parameter and
our our other things so we'll fix those
in a second in our animation if this is
an entering animation so if entering is
true then we need to await
tween finished and when it
is then we
emit so again we're we're checking if
this is an entering animation we're
going to set that in a second if it is
we're going to wait for that animation
to finish and then we will emit the
entered signal and that's going to
Cascade start all the other animations
that are waiting for this one to finish
let's go ahead and fix all of these
other ones so if we are uh on ENT
remember this is our reset the zero or
whatever your enter settings are we
don't need this to be an entering
animation we don't want to emit when
this one's done so we set that to false
and we do have to uh also fix our our
binds here although technically I guess
you could just set it to false um but if
we're hovering we don't need to set this
as an entering animation we set that to
false and if we are UNH hovering we set
it to false false we're not entering the
only place that we will be entering
using this entering animation is right
here so onenter function reset
everything to our zero if we're waiting
for something then we're waiting if not
then we're running our entering
animation and here is where we want to
set it to true so this will run this
will liit everything else can follow
after that I that might be a little
confusing I hope not trying trying to
explain it as best as I can but it'll
make sense when it runs because it does
work now we're not actually done yet
because we are emitting this signal but
the the thing that the thing that's
waiting for this to emit doesn't
actually know that it's doing that it
doesn't know what to do so we need to
make another signal connection with this
entered uh signal so we'll go back to
our connect signals function up here and
we're going to add a if we're waiting
for something we need to take that know
that we're we're waiting for and connect
its entered signal that we
created and we need to connect it to our
add twe just like we did with the hover
on and the hover off and we'll make this
nice and clean like we did with the
other ones and we'll fill out our
parameters this will be whoop we'll fill
out our parameters this will be default
values parallel
animations enter time because this is
going to be the inter animation remember
enter
delay enter
transition enter
easing and let's say that this node is
being waited on by something else so
this needs also to be set the true and I
think we are good to go so let's test
this and in this case let's add uh let's
just show how easy this is now let's um
let's add an animation
to our panel container right let's make
the panel container pop up we'll add a
new animation component to our panel
container and we will set some settings
over here we'll make it do an inner
animation uh everything else is good
with default we won't worry about hover
and for the inner time let's do 0.5
seconds let's add just a little bit of a
delay and let's have it bounce in ease
in ease out we'll start from a scale of
zero it's going to go to a scale of one
and let's also um make it transparent to
the nontransparent let's just check that
animation
first boom there you go nice and easy if
we get rid of this delay it's going to
run at the same time so we want to wait
for our our panel to load and then let's
do our buttons so we go to our our new
game animation component that we've
added we'll change the weight for to our
panel container let's try it
now there we go so this animation the
entering animation waited for the panel
animation to finish and then it runs we
can also do the same thing with our
continue button in fact I think we're
running that already we're waiting for
the new game let's add another one
here to our third button have another
inner animation
zero it out linear is fine and let's
wait for our continue button to finish
have us take 05 so panel should run new
game should run continue should run then
settings should
run and there you go you just saw it
takes like 15 seconds to add a new
animation to the uh the settings button
and you have control of when it comes in
you can add a delay adjust all the
settings that you want I think this is a
good stopping point for our animation
portion at least getting it going um we
can jump into some user interfaces we
can start getting to the fun stuff as
always uh thanks for watching if you
want the source files you can grab on
patreon and uh yeah keep creating all
right guys if this tutorial was helpful
consider it a like And subscribe to the
channel as we're going to be covering a
lot more thanks to all of my patrons who
keep this series going you too can get
access to the project source files by
joining my Pat
you can download everything there and
you'll also get early access to my
videos and sneak peeks at Future
tutorials thanks for watching and as
always keep creating
[Music]